[inaudible]
what would my advice be to a driven and
intelligent college student or young
person about to enter
the real world? Well,
I would be very simple.
It would be focus on
learning instead of earning,
and that sounds cliche,
but I'll explain why because if you
want to make say $1 million a year,
$10 million a year instead
of $100,000 a year,
I would argue you probably don't want to
take the a hundred thousand dollar per
year job, even if it's offered
to you right out of the gate.
I know it sounds like a lot of money,
but what I'm going to recommend
is not limited to finances.
You want to focus on
projects, on companies,
on environments where you can learn
lessons on someone else's bankroll.
All right?
So let them pay for it and view it
effectively as an apprenticeship.
So find a situation where you can be
in the room with masters of a craft and
that could just be dealmaking. It
could be joining a small company,
say a fewer than 50 people,
where you simply get to observe one of
the principals negotiating in an industry
that you don't even care
anything about, right?
It could be waste management and
you want to go into high tech,
but if you sit in a room with someone
who's an absolute pro at crafting deals,
negotiating, getting past no those skills,
and maybe those relationships
start to snowball. All right?
And this is what Scott Adams,
the creator of Dilbert
would call systems thinking.
So instead of being wedded to
the outcome of a given job,
you are accumulating skills and
relationships that transcend that job,
okay? And if you choose your environments,
well, because as I've said before,
and as people like drew, the CEO
of Dropbox, as a friend have said,
you're the average of the five people
you associate with most, right?
So if you take just a few
years, have the patients,
the few years to really develop core
competencies that allow you to craft your
own reality and life negotiation,
deal making, getting past know,
et Cetera, learning how to pitch,
how to get someone's attention in 30
seconds so that you can then create the
desire and ultimately ask for some
type of action. Once you develop those,
then you can really just create the map
for the next decade and the next several
decades. So that would be it.
It would be learned before you earn
and it's never too late to do that.
So I don't care if you're coming out
of college, coming out of high school,
30 40 whatever it is, systems thinking,
focus on the skills and relationships
first and then you can just create a blank
check for how much money you want to
make. If that is your goal. The guys,
if you're enjoying the tips and tactics
and how to on this channel or in the
podcast, the Tim Ferriss show, I
made this for you. Tribe of mentors,
short advice from the best in the world.
This is the book that I wanted to read.
So I went out and I put it together,
created a dream list of 130
of the best at what they do.
People who are icons, legends, and
ask them all the same questions.
These are people in some cases
I wanted to reach out to.
My whole life ranges from
many, many billionaires,
cofounders of every company imaginable,
elite athletes ranging from surfing to
tennis to power lifting. Everything else,
country stars, actors, directors,
and you can spot the patterns.
So some of my friends have said
this is the easiest to read,
most useful book that
I've put together yet.
So checking out tribal mentors.com
you can find sample chapters,
the whole list of mentors,
everything, mentor, mentors.com.